so what we have here is four different
values some of them expressed with the
negative numbers and/or absolute value
and what I want to do is I want to sort
them from least to greatest where the
least is on the left and the greatest is
on the right so sort from least to
greatest and like always and encourage
you to pause the video and try to work
through it on your own so I'm assuming
you've you had a try at it so these is
way I can think about it is well let's
just let's just plot them all on a
number line and you might want to draw
it out or eventually you kind of have a
number line in your head and you can
think about it that way so let's first
think about the absolute value of
negative 27 so what is the absolute
value of negative 27 what's just going
to be positive 27 this right over here
is the same thing as positive 27 because
negative 27 is 27 to the left of 0 27 to
the left of zero so let's plot the
absolute value of negative 27 well it's
really 27 so it's going to be right over
here so that is the absolute value of
negative 27 it is positive 27 all right
then we have negative 17 well negative
17 let's see each hash mark here is 3 so
this is negative 9 negative 12 negative
15 so negative 17 is going to be right
around there so that is negative 17 then
we have negative 28 so we have negative
27 and each hash mark is 3 so negative
28 is going to be right over there
negative 28 and then finally we have
22.4 so let's see we have 18 21 22 would
be here so 22 point 4 is going to be
roughly right over there so that is 22
point 4 so if we want to sort it from
least to greatest well we just have to
start at the left end of the number line
delete the smallest of them or the least
of them is negative 28 then we go to
negative 17 negative 17 then we go to
22.4 then we go to 22.4 and then we go
to the absolute value of negative 27
and we are done